saviez vous que chaque minute six
personnes supplémentaires se retrouve
dans la précarité
ne trouvez-vous pas cette situation
frappante il ya plus de 25 ans déjà
j'étais très préoccupés par le chômage
en france
c'est très émouvant parce que vous allez
comprendre par les yeux effectivement
c'est très préoccupant et la chômage en
fait celle isolement c'est la solitude
c'est l'exclusion en moyenne selon les
chiffres officiels aujourd'hui plus de
10 mois sont nécessaires pour retrouver
un poste
encore faut-il avoir un réseau pour
retrouver un travail il ya 25 ans
j'avais compris que le chômage était
quelque chose déjà inévitable
alors comment fait aujourd'hui des
institutions des organismes existent
sont organisées au silo et ne communique
pas aux poudres entre elles il ya cinq
ans j'avais 40 ans je me suis retrouvé
pris dans un plan social
ces fameux plan de sauvegarde de
l'emploi
à l'époque je travaillais comme
responsable informatique d'un grand
groupe financier
rapidement j'ai voulu savoir combien de
temps allait durer ce plan j'ai regardé
sur internet j'ai vu que j'avais entre
12 et 18 mois avant effectivement me
retrouver son emploi est au chômage
comme beaucoup de professionnels
j'ai tout de suite pensé j'ai retrouvé
grâce à mon réseau
j'ai très vite réalisé j'avais quasiment
pas de réseau
j'ai alors regardé toutes mes cartes de
visite je me suis aperçu que la plupart
étaient obsolètes
j'ai alors décidé d'ouvrir un compte
linkedin et de toutes les transférer
dans cet outil est finalement au delà de
cette création de réseaux j'ai également
comptait commencer à partager les
informations
quelques
plus tard est également ouvert un compte
twitter de nouveau j'ai partagé de
l'actualité et j'ai commencé à écrire
des articles
finalement au bout d'un an je me suis
effectivement retrouvé sans emploi à la
fin du plan social
mais je suis assez une semaine au
chômage grâce à cette visibilité grâce à
ses réseaux j'ai transformé cette
période d'un an ont une fantastique
opportunité pour rebondir et pour aller
vers un nouvel emploi toutes les
stations c'est le bon nom rappelle
l'expérience d'un proche un proche qui a
45 ans il ya plus de 20 ans s'est
retrouvé au chômage
il a commencé à chercher du travail
c'était à l'époque rédacteur en chef
professionnelle relais sémantique
exceptionnel j'étais en admiration
devant lui j'avais 23 ans et je me
disais mon cou noir
pourquoi je cherche du travail
j'en avais parlé à ma mère judy si c'est
bizarre en temps moi je trouve du
travail et l'humain n'y arrive pas
pourquoi et j'ai vite rapidement compris
qu'en fait déjà à l'époque c'était pas
seulement aura des compétences pas
seulement avoir du talent qu'il fallait
avoir c'était un réseau vous savez ces
fameuses bonne personne ces personnes
qui sont nécessaires tu n'as moyens au
bon moment c'est pas forcément ce qu'il
faut c'est juste avoir une bonne
connexion qu'elle utile de moins que les
autres ont même acheté lui avec les
mêmes compétences fort parfois moins de
compétences que lui pour réussir à
trouver quelques missions
la violence de sa femme sont habillés
veillance de sa famille de ses proches
il aurait pu tomber dans un internat au
total il aurait pu se trouver alors oui
alors justement
encore faut-il être connectés et parade
connectés il faut justement retrouver un
réseau social
et pour avoir un réseau social il faut
sortir pour rencontrer du monde comme
toi j'ai toujours été préoccupé par le
fait qu'il fallait mettre en avant des
personnes en recherche d'emploi depuis
très longtemps sur mon blog je mettais
en avant ces personnes je partager leurs
compétences pour leur offrir de la
visibilité et un jour à l'ancien député
européen m'a contactée sur twitter il
m'a envoyé un message
alban à côté de chez moi
une usine en corrèze va être liquidée
dans dix jours
pouvez vous m'aider à la sauver avec vos
réseaux vous pouvez m'aider à sauver 30
emplois sauvés une usine en corrèze
depuis paris ça me semblait totalement
impossible et ça les fait en tous les
cas seuls alors un samedi matin j'ai
contacté 15 minutes sur les réseaux
sociaux dont karine et ensemble très
rapidement nous avons décidé que nous
pourrions essayer que nous allons
utiliser twitter pour donner de la
visibilité à cette usine est en quelques
heures nous allons fonder ce collectif
au tournant hashtag un simple le hashtag
dix ans plus tard
l'argent est arrivé et la ville
d'eysines a été prolongée d'un mois
au bout d'un mois le repreneur a eu sept
dossiers sur son bureau
alors même si notre initiative nous
n'étions pas seuls parce que la presse
aussi a pris le relais les une nouvelle
france bleu on parlait de ce collectif
qui était en train d'essayer de sauver
une usine en corrèze
l'usiné a été sauvée ce fut
extraordinaire on peut pas s'arrêter là
il fallait continuer le bout d'un mois
nous étions déjà 500 à participer à ce
collectif et nous allons transformer
pour aider les personnes qui étaient en
recherche d'emploi pour aider des
personnes qui avaient besoin d'avoir un
réseau et qu'il n'avait pas ou à aider
ces personnes qui avaient besoin
gratuitement d'être aidés et nous avons
décidé continuer car il peut tout
expliquer comment fonctionne leur emploi
alors par le biais de twitter
une personne julie en recherche de corps
nous contacter elle me transfère en fait
son cv
et puis son propre compte finalement
elle pense qu une infographie avec un
message en expliquant qu'elle est en
recherche d'emploi elle est le graphiste
et on se rend vite compte que finalement
son cv est trop long trop long pour les
réseaux sociaux rempli trotte alors
immédiatement notre collectif
les bénévoles un quotidien en privé
l'aide helvétique comment par des mots
clés met en valeur ses compétences ses
talents sur cette infographie et là elle
me rends compte à quelques jours après
elle me dit c'est incroyable ça je le
prêt j'ai deux entretiens elle nous
contacter qu'enthousiaste 5 est bercée
de centimes et je vous dis juste merci
quoi et là en fait comment fonctionne un
effort emploi donc comme je le disais
tout à l'heure à truites à personne
depuis son propre compte
posté un message avec une infographie en
mettant en avant ses talents ses
compétences
ensuite le hashtag il faut emploi et
grâce à ce phare grâce à ce hashtag nous
sommes tous mobilisés tous organisés
pour toi tes airs tout et grâce à mon
tweet et noro tweet ici tweet à elle
elle a obtenu une visibilité que jamais
elle aurait pu la voir en quelques
heures
un truc de dingue de tout temps dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
des personnes ont réussi à en mobiliser
d'autres sont parvenus envoyer les
signaux en réseau ainsi au nom de la
guerre d'indépendance des états unis
quand les corps et les anglais
commençaient à arriver
deux cavaliers ont été missionnés pour
aller mobiliser des troupes pour se
défendre contre l'arrivée des anglais
william dose le premier estimé
comment prévenir les personnes qui
étaient les plus influents de son réseau
des personnes qu'il connaissait il
allait pouvoir mobiliser son message à
tourner en rond et s'est arrêté il n'a
quasiment 1000 des personnes al'inverse
paul reeber ce cavalier est passé de
village en village de ville en ville
pour lancer le signal de la mobilisation
les anglais arrivent mobilisez vous en
une nuit
quarante cavaliers ont pris son relais
et le matin des troupes étaient
mobilisés paris veut avancer dans
l'histoire des états unis
il est inscrit dans cette libération des
états unis ce hashtag fonctionne
exactement de la même façon
grâce à cet appel il va partir dans des
réseaux de personnes qui ne sont pas
connus de la personne en recherche
d'emploi ce réseau va lui offrir de la
visibilité et ce réseau va démultiplier
son impact et à la fin peut-être
permettre à la personne de retrouver un
emploi
alors aujourd'hui mon seul nom après
deux ans d'existence
deux ans plus de 200 personnes ont
trouvé un travail de 700 personnes sont
accompagnés nous sommes plus de 2000
bénévoles avec un million d'abonnés
cumuler la force devient puissante les
institutions aujourd'hui nous demandent
mon 10mai comment est ce que vous faites
on leur dit essayer de ne pas reproduire
un modèle mais d'essayer de regarder
comment ça se passe au quotidien et nous
avons effectivement on essaie de
travailler avec les institutions pour
être complémentaires parce qu'on croit à
la complémentarité nous sommes des
bénévoles c'est un don de notre temps on
a des valeurs communes qui sont
l'empathie et la bienveillance
donc en fait aujourd'hui on s'est bien
rendu compte comme on le disait tout à
l'heure que les talents les compétences
ne sont plus suffisants voyez ce proche
si déjà il ya plus de vingt ans il avait
eu ce type d'outil
il a mis cinq ans à retrouver un poste 5
ans c'est donc cinq ans il mois deux
mois pourquoi est ce que j'ai fait les
bonnes personnes être chômage 50 ans
c'est une catastrophe
seulement 13% des personnes ayant plus
de 50 ans retrouve rapidement un emploi
pour les jeunes de moins de 25 ans c'est
exactement la même chose
25 % d'entre eux ne retrouve pas un
travail avant même de sa rentrée sur le
marché non plus
dans les deux cas de figure on a des
générations qui sont complètement
sacrifiés alors personnellement je suis
convaincue qu'il est de devoir de tout
professionnel du devoir de tout citoyen
d'essayer d'aider les personnes à
retrouver un emploi
avec ce collectif nous essayons de le
faire tous les jours mais je pense que
quelle que soit la méthode
finalement il est de ne devoir d'essayer
et comme le disait nelson mandela être
libre ce n'est pas seulement essayé de
se débarrasser de ses chaînes sévit de
manière à respecter et à renforcer la
liberté des autres
merci
[Applaudissements]